Corée du Nord un plan pour survivre
documentaire signé mine joue Song qui
nous rappelle qu'un pays sur cette
planète vit en totale autarcie sous
l'autorité d'un tyran qui n'hésitent pas
à envoyer sa population dans des camps
où à l'exécuter au moindre soupçon de
déloyauté un pays qui intrigue qui
interroge avec nous pour en parler
aujourd'hui Pierre Aski bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste à France Inter on vous
retrouve tous les jours dans la matinale
dans votre chronique géopolitique vous
êtes aussi président de Reporters sans
frontières vous êtes le co-réalisateur
avec minjousson justement du
documentaire intitulé La princesse rouge
de Corée du Nord et puis vous êtes le
co-auteur avec Pascal Blanchard et Farid
abdelwab de ce livre les années 50 et si
la guerre froide recommençait Marie
orangerais bienvenue à vous également
vous êtes historienne spécialiste de la
Corée contemporaine à l'Université Paris
Cité et puis vous êtes membre du
laboratoire CCJ Chine Corée Japon
Michael stanck bienvenue à vous vous
êtes journaliste reporters écrivain
producteur et réalisateur chez bubble
doc vous à trois reprises en Corée du
Nord la dernière fois c'était en 2014 de
cette expérience vous en avez tiré un
documentaire vous aussi Corée du Nord la
grande illusion et puis une BD la faute
une vie en Corée du Nord Olivier
Guillard bienvenue à vous vous êtes
géopolitologue spécialiste de l'Asie
chercheur associé à l'Institut d'études
de géopolitique appliquées directeur de
l'information chez Chris 24 un cabinet
de conseil spécialisé dans l'analyse et
la gestion des risques internationaux
vous êtes chargé de cours à les Deck et
enfin vous êtes l'auteur de que faire
avec la Corée du Nord subir enir ou
punir bienvenue à tous les quatre il y a
une question qu'on se pose tout au long
de ce film en tout cas que moi je me
suis posé c'est ce que les Nord-Coréens
sont dupes est-ce qu'ils croient
vraiment en la légende des Kim comment
peuvent-ils se plier aux règles qui leur
sont imposées avec autant d'obéissance
Michael Stan avez-vous un début de
réponse à cette question un début de
réponse uniquement un début puisque même
en y étant allait plusieurs fois c'est
difficile de percer ce mystère
aussi c'est un mystère parce que
je pense que une bonne partie de la
population adhère au système à des
systèmes une partie de la population la
plus démunis celle qui est dans les
campagnes celle qui qui a vraiment du
mal à survivre
en privé c'est ce que raconte les
transfuges en tout cas disent que voilà
ils ont jamais eu pire que ce qu'ils
vivent aujourd'hui
après
entre subir et vivre cette cette
dictature la vraie question c'est
comment vivre autrement et comment
contester le régime quand on a peur en
fait quand on a peur de de dire les
choses d'être d'être dénoncé par son
voisin donc il y a beaucoup de non-dit
donc c'est difficile de percer ces
non-dit évidemment surtout quand on est
étranger avec le peu d'accès qu'on a
même quand on est dans le pays c'est un
peu compliqué une soumission d'abord
liée à la peur
elle a peur d'être différent c'est à
dire que il y a une il y a un risque à
ne pas penser comme les autres le le
quadrillage la délation le surveillance
sont elles que c'est très dangereux de
de s'autoriser même dans sa tête à
diverger mais j'ai pas mal travaillé sur
la Roumanie après chez scoop et je me
souviens de d'une femme qui m'avait
raconté qu'elle avait été dénoncée par
son mari à la police de Tchao parce
qu'elle fredonnait des chansons
américaines qu'elle avait entendu la
télévision yougoslave et pour
s'interdire de penser elle s'était mise
au piano parce qu'elle passait des
heures à faire des gammes sur son piano
pour s'interdire de penser et ça me fait
souvent penser à ça la Corée du Nord
c'est à dire il y a un danger y compris
dans la famille dans la cellule dans le
voisinage
et ça c'est c'est peut-être la chose la
plus
vérifiante c'est à dire l'idée qu'on
s'interdise de penser parce que penser
c'est déjà dangereux
c'est ça qu'on doit comprendre alors le
lavage de cerveau oui depuis la très
jeune enfant bon la propagande à tous
les niveaux à l'École etc mais il y a
aussi cette dimension qui est mentionnée
dans dans le documentaire de secte voilà
cette croyance qui à mon sens relève
vraiment de la secte et c'est vrai que
pour des personnes qui sont dans une
secte souvent c'est très difficile de ne
plus adhérer de changer et j'en sais
autrement voilà
je pense qu'il y a il y a une et c'est
vraiment entretenu par par le régime
donc dans le parti vous avez les dix
commandements du parti etc il y a des
références un petit peu religieuses
quand même quelque part et ça je pense
que c'est très très fort et les
Nord-Coréens finalement et bien ils ont
très peu de choix très peu de marge de
manœuvre même si certains pour se rendre
compte de certaines choses
psychologiquement en fait reconnaître
qu'on a pu avoir tort et je pense que ça
c'est très difficile et où est
l'idéologie dans tout cela le film
l'évoque très rapidement le jeu de chez
je vais expliquer un petit peu ce que
c'est pour les téléspectateurs c'est
l'idéologie officielle du régime
nord-coréen et voilà ce que j'ai lu sur
le sujet dans un média sud-coréen au
cinquième congrès du Parti des
travailleurs de 1970 le terme joue-t-il
est inscrit dans les statues du parti
comme idéologie officielle en 74 le
joutché est officiellement rebaptisé le
kiwilson Games ou kimisme un système de
pensée révolutionnaire unique on
distingue alors le kimisme du marxisme
léninisme le premier étant considéré
comme supérieur au second Olivier
Guillard ce peuple tient aussi sur une
idéologie et pas seulement sur la peur
alors l'idéologie je pense qu'elle a
largement laissé céder le pas ces
dernières décennies donc à la réalité
matérielle à savoir celle de une société
totalement orwellienne où il est
impossible de penser par soi-même on
doit même la surveillance à ses petits
enfants ou et vice-versa où on contraint
à tout le monde de la journée on est
dans une sorte de mascara de permanente
avec une peur mais de tous les instants
imaginez un petit peu on est à des à des
galaxies un petit peu d'un mode
d'existence et Dieu merci pour nous
comme cela aujourd'hui donc la il y a
des gens de toute évidence de diverses
de la société vous allez rencontrer
éventuellement donc à l'étranger ou dans
le pays c'est notre cas qui ont une
profonde croyance parce que d'une
manière générale au bout de trois
générations où on est contraint de
penser comme ça on finit peut-être par y
croire un petit peu le monde est au
style on nous le répète tous les matins
à 6h du matin de l'école à l'usine de la
rue au métro on peut donc il y a des
gens qui sont convaincus je prends un
exemple que je dont je rêve de le détail
de rencontrer des diplomates
nord-coréens en poste en Europe
occidentale ça m'est arrivé depuis une
petite vingtaine d'années ce sont des
gens donc qui ont un accès au monde
extérieur à la réalité un petit peu qui
la nôtre qui savent très bien que le
monde entier ne l'aurait pas hostile qui
se moque dans une grande mesure de la
Corée du Nord tant qu'elle n'est pas
menaçante et pourtant donc vous cette
façade a des appareils en fait dont la
famille est restée au pays pour des
raisons de fidélité que nécessaire que
l'on ne que l'on devine assez bien et
ces individu dont tiennent à des
discours de propagande en comprenant
bien que je me suis toujours pas la
question ça va est-ce que c'est individu
là qui est visiblement assez bien
cérébré donc il y a des patrons que je
ne voudrais pas avoir évidemment qui a
des comptes à rendre mais pensent-ils
vraiment jusqu'au bout de sa phrase et
de la ponctuation ce qu'il nous assène
tout au long de ce film quand on les
retrouve mais c'est pas possible comment
peuvent-ils croire si vous me permettez
un dernier petit mot à propos de ce
documentaire donc je le trouve à titre
personnel relativement bien il est riche
je pense que les téléspectateurs donc
auront appris ou réappris un certain
nombre de choses il dresse un portrait
assez assassin de ce qu'elle d'origine
chimiste et c'est tout à fait normal
aujourd'hui
bravo c'est réalisateur et bravo comme
un hiver aussi bien sûr avec la
différence quand même entre Pyongyang et
le reste du pays ou pas est-ce qu'il y a
une différence
c'est forcément la vitrine parce que il
y a une représentée il y a des
représentants étrangers alors la passer
dernier temps avec le covid mais il y a
des ambassade il y a des il y a même des
groupes de touristes qui viennent
au compte-goutte mais qui sont autorisés
il y a les grands rassemblements etc
donc la capitale c'est la vitrine et
effectivement toutes les tous les
phénomènes de famine qu'on a pu
connaître par exemple dans les années 90
etc
commence par des rumeurs qui arrivent du
reste du pays des gens qui ont pu voir
ou expérimenter des choses loin de la
capitale et et les phénomènes arrivent
beaucoup plus atténués et étouffé dans
la capitale donc il y a un fossé entre
Pyongyang et le reste on s'aperçoit en
fait quand on quand on va Pyongyang et
qu'on a la possibilité de sortir de
Pyong évidemment de la vitrine qui est
la capitale mais surtout ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les qui habitent en
dehors de Pyongyang n'ont pas le droit
de venir à Pyongyang et dont paroi de
s'installer à Pyongyang il faut les
autorisations spéciales dans le pays
pour pour traverser le pays il faut
faire peur
c'est ce qu'on appelle vie à Pyongyang
ce qu'on appelle les masses du noyau du
noyau de la masse populaire pardon vous
voyez la masse populaire c'est
d'ailleurs les élites les étudiants les
proches des familles politiques etc et
qui a une classification en plus dans le
dans le pays classification par par
comment dire par fidélité politique de
la population donc plus on est fidèle à
la au régime nord-coréen depuis la
fondation de la Corée du Nord depuis la
partition plus on a le droit d'habiter
dans le plan milongue en fait c'est ce
que me racontait des guides racontent ça
enfin il explique très bien d'ailleurs
donc les paysans agriculteurs qui
représentent une bonne partie de la
population donc on aura de toute façon
de se rendre à Pyongyang sans
autorisation
oui la pureté idéologique extrêmement
importante pour structurer les classes
sociales en Corée du Nord et c'est vrai
que vous parliez de tout à l'heure du
jutsche cette idéologie indigène si je
puis dire qui prône en fait
l'indépendance l'auto-suffisance etc et
qui permet de justifier les sacrifices
de la population par exemple et
également qui permet de justifier la
diplomatie de la Corée du Nord à
équidistance de la Chine et de l'Union
soviétique puis maintenant de la Russie
c'est qui mülsong était un fin stratège
diplomate pour permettre à ce petit pays
de survivre et c'est alors c'est vrai
que c'est un système extrêmement
absolutiste quelque part mais c'est très
efficace en tout cas dans tous les pays
du monde qui ont connu ou qui
connaissent encore des régimes
autoritaires très autoritaires il y a
toujours saela des débuts de rébellion
des mouvements contestataires en Corée
du Nord on a l'impression peut-être que
ce n'est qu'une impression vous me le
direz que ça n'existe pas du tout à part
peut-être des envies clandestine
d'écouter ou de regarder des films
sud-coréens
en regardant les séries sud-coréennes
les habitants du Nord commencent à
changer dans leur façon de vivre de
s'habiller ou de se coiffer tout ça
c'est tolérable mais il parle de plus en
plus comme des Sud-Coréens et ils ont de
moins en moins de fierté ou de loyauté
pour leur grand leader ça ce n'est pas
acceptable on n'a pas
Olivier c'est la seule rébellion
existante en Corée du Nord c'est de
regarder des séries supérieures
évidemment si cela se limite à ce genre
de choses évidemment vous voyez un petit
peu qu'on est loin de faire tomber le
régime il s'agit pas d'écouter des CD de
K-Pop ou de regarder des des séries
sud-corrènes aussi
la main dans le sac généralement ils
sont pris la main dans le sac et leur
entourage immédiat la famille
le responsable de la surveillance de
l'étage de l'immeuble de la résidence
qui n'a pas remonté un petit peu
l'information vous voyez donc c'est un
petit peu c'est pour ça que le régime
tient d'une manière aussi et aussi
redoutable et c'est pour cela que quand
bien même il y aura des dissidences au
sein du parti au sein de l'armée au sein
de la société ou au sein de tout ce qui
peut exister représenter dans les
provinces ou dans le centre de du
pouvoir un semblant de dissidence de
mécontentement le risque est simplement
trop grand c'est peut-être toute la
force un petit peu c'est une dictature
au sens absolutisme du terme tout à fait
raison elle aujourd'hui elle est
probablement contestée dans les esprits
par une masse importante de ces 25
millions de nord-coré mais combien sont
courageux ceux qui ont le qui ont le
Toupé ne serait-ce que de penser ou
fredonner donc une un air qui pourrait
faire penser que squid Games a été lu en
douce au regardait en douce à partir
d'une journée à mort dénoncé par ses
parents pour avoir regardé exactement et
nous avons des exemples comme ça qui
sont encore plus horribles donc est-ce
qu'on sait s'il y a un début de début de
début dons de rébellion de mouvement de
côté sur une presse clandestine quelque
chose qui existe dans normalement tous
les régimes autorités ça existe mais en
dehors en dehors de la péninsule mais
pas en Corée du Nord alors en Corée du
Nord depuis 48 si on regarde l'histoire
on voit un certain nombre de purges qui
ont eu lieu par exemple en 57 très
importante etc pour purger des
communistes pro chinois ou enfin etc et
mais en fait ça a toujours été contrôlé
et pendant la famille on sait qu'il y a
eu des rébellions enfin il y a eu des
choses qui se sont passées plus
récemment l'oncle du leader actuel bon
qui a été purgé également donc il y a
quand même
des actes de rébellion donc qui qui sont
réprimés venant d'individus donc Michel
il y a même plus récemment cette je
crois que c'est en début d'année il y a
eu des actes de rébellion contre la
police en fait non Cohen on le sait
pareil par des transfuses et par des par
les réseaux de nord-coré en Corée du Sud
lié au covid le covid a fait beaucoup de
mal en fait à la Corée du Nord encore
plus et l'ami dans une difficulté encore
plus importante que celle qu'elle vivait
aujourd'hui puisque la Corée du Nord a
fait une chose à la fermer tout de suite
ses frontières en 2019 et elles jouent
au portes donc j'avais fait beaucoup de
mal surtout sur le commerce
transfrontalier qui existait avec la
Chine et sur justement ce début ce début
quand même de de de combien de marchés
clandestins qui a tout qui est qu'il y a
entre la Chine et la Corée du Nord c'est
souvent par là que les que les que les
séries les DVD de série sud-coréenne
transit et là aujourd'hui tout est fermé
tout est et juste pour ajouter un petit
point il y a eu plusieurs commissariat
en fait nord-coréen qui ont été attaqués
par les par les gens n'ont pas pour une
pour des raisons politiques mais pour
des raisons tout simplement de famine en
fait et de fin
il y a une chose à noter c'est aussi
toute la les tentatives faites par les
églises
notamment protestantes
sud-coréenne qui sont très actifs pour
faire passer de l'information
de qui font du prosélytisme aussi du
côté du Nord cette cette activité des
des
églises sud-coréennes et très importants
et en particulier via la Chine c'est eux
qui essaye de d'aider les réfugiés qui
passent parce que le paradoxe nord-coré
c'est que pour quitter pour s'enfuir du
pays on ne peut aller que vers la Chine
qui n'est pas très hospitalière
vis-à-vis des Nord-Coréens qui renvoient
les gens quand elles quand elle peut
donc
le retour est impossible en Corée du
Nord une fois qu'ils sont partis
pourront plus jamais revenir tous ceux
qu'on entend d'ailleurs dans le document
qui sont passés en Corée du Sud
difficilement parce qu'une fois qu'on
est en Chine on n'est pas sorti
d'affaires il faut arriver à sortir de
Chine et atteindre la Corée du Sud
souvent ça se passe par par le Cambodge
par exemple ou par la Thaïlande donc il
faut aller très loin pour faire un
détour pour arriver encore et du Sud et
encore du Sud ils sont pas
particulièrement heureux il faut bien le
dire parce que un adaptation à une
société capitaliste même coréenne n'est
pas facile de il y a souvent du racisme
ou du mépris vis-à-vis de gens qui ont
pas les codes de de cette société et qui
ont l'impression d'être d'être méprisé
c'est c'est très compliqué je pense de
de
se refaire une vie après après la Corée
du Nord que ces dernières années enfin
depuis que Kim Jong-un donc depuis une
petite douzaine d'années et a suivi les
pas de son père de son grand-père à la
tête de ses dictatures le nombre de
personnes réussissant à quitter le
territoire n'ont pas qu'elles ne le
veuillent plus mais qui réussissent à
sortir à ne pas se faire prendre en
route a été divisé par X donc il y a de
moins en moins de monde qui
malheureusement ce qui ne veut pas dire
que les gens sont de plus en plus
heureux c'est à dire qu'ils ont de moins
en moins d'opportunité le point qui
était évoqué à l'instant est tout à fait
pertinent il y a un
à mieux être physique quotidien pour les
exilés nord-coré qui arrive en Corée du
Sud mais l'adaptation est difficile et
les cas de déprime de
dépression de dépression sont assez
nombreux et la propagande nord-coréenne
souvent donc réussi de temps à autre à
faire revenir un vrai ou un faux
nord-coréen exilés et de retour en
disant écouté ce brave homme était
tellement mieux dans notre paradis qu'il
a quitté cet enfer sud-corain démontrant
s'il était besoin pour l'état de la
propagande d'un nord-coréenne que le
bonheur est au nord et non au sud et que
tout tentative en fait est compliqué
sanctionner et en plus ce n'est pas
garanti que cela vous plaise ça marche
évidemment pas spécialement chez les
nord-coré qui sont au courant parce
qu'ils sont de plus en plus ils se
doutent bien qu'au sud les gens vivent
mieux quand ils ont probablement 50 fois
plus de ressources au quotidien que
leurs enfants ne sont pas contraints
dénoncer leurs parents etc
il faut bien comprendre que la Corée du
Sud n'est pas très tendre avec les
nord-corains comme Pierre le disait mais
même le gouvernement n'est pas très
tendre non plus c'est à dire que ils
arrivent ils sont obligés de débriefer
les services secrets non sont obligés de
débriefer tous les tous les nouveaux
arrivants pour éviter qu'il y ait des
espions parmi parmi eux ça dure deux
mois ils sont les Nordiens sont enfermés
pendant 60 jours dans un centre de dans
un centre qui est en Corée du Sud à côté
de Séoul de de je sais pas comment on
appelle ça un centre où on débrief en
tout cas les et c'est très très
compliqué pour eux j'avais interrogé moi
une une femme qui avait été débriefée
donc par des autorités sud-coréennes qui
étaient transfuges en Corée du Sud qui
avait été traumatisé par ce moment-là 60
jours on lui demande tout et n'importe
quoi elle qui ne connaît pas en fait la
Corée du Sud quand elle arrive alors
comment ce pays en est-il arrivé à ce
degré de fermeture et de fermeté quand
et comment s'est-il replié sur lui-même
le film fait un très long rappel
historique avec beaucoup d'étapes il y a
notamment ce tournant c'est la chute de
l'URSS regardez
[Musique]
à la fin de l'année 1989 je pense que
c'était en décembre fut un signal
dramatique pour le leadership
nord-coréen et je pense que c'est une
raison essentielle qui a empêché les
réformes et l'ouverture du pays
l'Union soviétique était le parrain de
la Corée du Nord lui fournissant une
large assistance matérielle mais avec
l'effondrement de l'URSS se soutient a
disparu dans le même temps la Chine
souhaitait renforcer ses relations
diplomatiques avec la Corée du Nord le
Nord s'est senti isolé trahi et ils ont
senti qu'il devait prendre leur sécurité
en main et augmenter leur effort pour
développer des armes nucléaires
la chute de l'URSS est un tournant pour
la Corée du Nord oui effectivement un
tournant en fait la Corée du Nord a été
contrainte de changer son système
économique
là on pouvait faire du troc il y avait
une réciprocité une entraide des pays
frères etc et puis d'un seul coup plus
rien et c'est vrai que la Corée du Nord
c'est aussi dans les années 90 qu'elle a
eu des problèmes au niveau de kalamité
naturelle des sécheresses etc qui ont
engendré une famille et c'est vrai qu'en
quand les gens commencent à déterrer les
pouces pour les manger mais on a plus de
récolte et c'est vrai que là ça a
vraiment profondément meurtrie le pays
et forcer la Corée du Nord à partir des
années
2000 et 2010 à changer de système
économique à libéraliser une certaine
nombre d'activités et donc vraiment un
changement absolument colossal pour les
Nord-Coréens qui pourtant doivent
conserver la même loyauté le un système
qui lui idéologiquement n'a pas changé
mais avec des activités qui changent
donc c'est le début de l'isolement de
l'autarcie de la fermeture totale c'est
avec le principe le montant quotidien
qui est de dire écoutez le monde
extérieur nous est toujours hostile nous
sommes toujours techniquement en guerre
avec les États-Unis et avec la Corée du
Sud nous n'avons pas signé de traiter de
paix regardez ces sud-coréens et ses
japonais et ses américains ils sont
encore en train de faire des manœuvres
conjointes en mer sur la au sud du 38e
parallèle c'est pour ça prouve bien
qu'il y a des intentions entre
guillemets de revenir solder un petit
peu cette donc si nous sommes dans une
dans un univers qui peut vous paraître
parfois on sait jamais vendu aussi d'une
manière aussi transparente aussi
délicate c'est qu'il y a des nécessités
pour ça c'est que nous et nous sommes le
garant pour vous de votre survie mais
croyant croyez en la famille Kim croyant
notre juste cause etc etc etc et ça fait
effectivement dans trois générations
d'hommes que cela dure et d'une manière
totalement paradisale quand vous
discutez avec des des responsables
politiques sud-coréens et des
responsables politiques ou des
émissaires du gouvernement nord-coré
vous avez sentiments qui en a un des
deux qui a la plupart du temps à raison
un peu plus de soucis à se faire en
termes de longévitation poste ils sont
plutôt au sud qu'au nord évidemment je
préfère perdre un
démocratique plutôt que reste au pouvoir
donc sous un sous un régime totalitaire
comme celui-ci mais c'est le paradoxe de
cette
péninsule coréenne je pense qu'il faut
comprendre par rapport à 89 et la fin du
bloc communiste que la Corée du Nord a
toujours eu un statut à part elle elle
est un des mots qu'on n'a pas prononcé
jusqu'à présent c'est le nationalisme
c'est-à-dire que c'est un pays qui n'est
pas c'était pas l'équivalent de la de la
Tchécoslovaquie ou de la Hongrie dans le
pack de Varsovie c'est plus proche
peut-être et c'est pour ça que ce coup a
beaucoup impressionné c'est peut-être
plus proche de Le du statut un petit peu
différent qu'avait la Roumanie ou et
encore plus la Yougoslavie de Tito
c'est-à-dire des pôles un petit peu
excentrés par rapport au bloc soviétique
ce qui fait que
à la chute du mur et l'implosion de
l'URSS les Nord-Coréens ont perdu
beaucoup de d'avantages de soutien il y
avait de possibilités de troc etc avec
l'URSS mais ils n'ont pas perdu
leur raison d'être idéologique qui était
au contraire le duché l'autarcie et le
fait que la Corée du Nord était à une
spécificité et ça on le retrouve un
petit peu dans le sud aussi la nation
coréenne c'est quelque chose à part et
donc la Corée du Nord y ajoute cette
dimension politique et et
deuxième point ça a coïncidité avec
l'émergence de la Chine dans les années
90 la Chine a commencé sa sa montée en
puissance et et la Corée du Nord à
travers toute son histoire et
spécialiste de cet équilibrisme entre
Moscou et pk et de savoir trouver son
avantage dans la réalité c'est ce qu'on
comprend aussi dans le film entre la
Chine et la Corée du Nord on n'arrive
pas à bien savoir s'ils sont frères
ennemis ou ennemis tout court ou ils
sont quand on moi j'ai vécu Pékin et apk
on sent très bien que les dirigeants
chinois n'aiment pas le régime
nord-coréen c'est pas voilà le le les
chaque président chinois que ce soit
gianz Jamin routinta ou ou si à essayer
de convaincre les dirigeants
nord-coréens de prendre la voix chinoise
c'est-à-dire les réformes tout en
gardant le contrôle politique et donc
l'ouverture économique et à chaque fois
ils se sont heurtés à un mur il y a des
petites réformes il y a des changements
etc mais cosmétiques comparé à l'ampleur
de ce qui s'est passé la transformation
économique de la Chine et donc les il y
a une grande frustration du côté chinois
mais il y a un facteur qui rappelait
dans le dans le film c'est que la Chine
ne veut pas voir s'écrouler la Corée du
Nord parce que une réunification
aujourd'hui se ferait aux conditions du
Sud et donc les Américains pourraient
arriver à la frontière chinoise
qui est alors que la Corée du Nord est
aujourd'hui cette zone tampon qui tient
les les Américains
éloignés et ça c'est je pense la clé si
on regarde la géo stratégie locale de
cette région c'est la clé du point de
vue Pékin quel que soit l'antipathique
on puisse avoir pour les
bizarreries nord-coréennes et cette
obsession de l'arme nucléaire dans tout
cela dont il est beaucoup question dans
le film c'est une assurance vie pour la
Corée du Nord c'est comme ça qu'il faut
le voir tu as fait c'est le parapluie
qui permet d'échapper à tout et protéger
le régime donc en fait les Nord-Coréens
sont extrêmement fiers on a dit
nationalistes ça remonte à la résistance
anti-japonaise du début du 20e siècle
mais ils ont ils ont vu Hiroshima ils
ont été aux premières loges de de ces
bombes là donc ils savent tout à fait
que c'est une possibilité tout à fait
réelle et donc ils ont effectivement ils
se sont construits et ils ont mobilisé
toute la population et ça continue pour
pour cette défense et ce qui a de
nouveau dans les 10 dernières années
c'est justement le fait qu'il se disent
arriver à un statut de donc de puissance
nucléaires qui devrait théoriquement
leur laisser un peu de marge de
manoeuvre pour développer l'économie
développer les loisirs etc dans il y a
un espoir en Corée du Nord
paradoxalement pour le futur puisque
maintenant qu'on qu'ils sont protégés
ils peuvent ils peuvent envisager
l'avenir et pourtant en 2008 sous Kim
Jong-il donc pour sortir de la liste
noire des états soutenant le terrorisme
la Corée du Nord a fait croire au
lancement d'un processus de
dénucléarisation en souvient alors de
cette image qui a circulée de la
destruction de la tour de
refroidissement de la centrale nucléaire
de Young beaucoup ont douté de cette
volonté de dénucléarisation et
l'histoire leur a donné raison puisque 3
mois plus tard le processus de
réactivation de la centrale et relancer
il y a jamais eu de volonté finalement
de dénucléarisation c'était un écran de
fumée probablement même moins que cela
encore donc je pense que là je pense
nous ne sommes pas le seul la plupart
des personnes travaillant sur les
affaires et intercores sont quasiment
unanimes la les le régime nord-coré est
un excellent joueur d'échec faisons
comme étant
des attaques raisonnables testant les
limites maximales donc la décale elles
peuvent se heurter ils peuvent se
heurter à quelques à quelques
résistances une comète peu d'erreurs ils
savent très bien quelles sont les
faiblesses de leurs interlocuteurs quand
vous agitez le drapeau rouge de nous
avons l'armatomique et nous sommes
techniquement encore en guerre contre
vous ne faisons pas plus confiance au
sud donc qui sont des selon
des vallées donc de la puissante
Amérique du Nord les
[Musique]
donc vous l'évoquez un instant le régime
chinois est aussi assez mal à l'aise ils
disent oui on a loupé le coche on n'a
pas pu un moment ou un autre on n'a pas
réussi à contraindre à faire comprendre
à la Corée du Nord que il y avait une
limite à tout et nous avons laissé un
petit peu cette limite une fois que vous
avez un arsenal nucléaire et que vous
avez des vecteurs crédibles si l'on
regarde un petit peu de l'année dernière
qui était une année d'inflation en
balistique considérable courte portée
l'emporté que porter interprétaire pour
les missiles et donc le premier semestre
ils se sont un peu amusés on va dire
aussi en terme de provocation ils ont
très peu de déchets en définitive très
peu déchets donc c'est ils ont une
puissance malheureusement un arsenal ils
ont la matière difficile plutonium et
uranium Richie qu'il faut ils ont les
vecteurs donc balistiques tout au gamme
si je puis dire et ils ont un
savoir-faire qui est qui est donc avéré
bref une fois que vous avez réussi
depuis une vingtaine d'années à faire
semblant de dire oui on peut discuter
d'où le la rencontre un petit peu il y
avait peut-être un fond d'espoir aussi
entre Kim Jong-un et l'ancien président
de l'exécutif américain donc à deux
reprises 2018 et 2019 il y avait
peut-être là quelques possibilités
peut-être de ralentissement du programme
mais jamais de nord-coréen donc NON
intérêt à n'ont eu le pour idée de
dénucariser même même ne serait-ce qu'on
le veut un boulon de d'une
ogive certainement pas ce qui nous amène
au contraire la suite de ce débat et on
va y venir face à un tel régime que
peuvent faire ou que doivent faire les
démocraties occidentales le film
rappelle les tentatives de Donald Trump
qu'on l'aime ou qu'on n'aime pas
l'ancien président américain sa méthode
a eu le mérite de permettre de renouer
le contact avec le pays le plus isolé de
la planète mais la tentative de
rapprochement a échoué rappelle d'effet
à un œil en 2019
[Musique]
c'est une proposition unilatérale il
proposait de fermer young
une fermeture en échange de la
suppression de la plupart des sanctions
américaines
c'était déséquilibré et l'administration
Trump a eu raison de refuser
mais je pense que si les États-Unis
avaient répondu avec une proposition
réaliste alors on aurait peut-être fait
des progrès
mais là humilié
[Musique]
quelque chose là je ne crois pas en fait
parce que parce que comme on le disait
juste avant le la Corée du Nord n'a
jamais eu l'intention de dénucléariser
pour la princesse rouge le documentaire
dans que vous avez cité j'ai rencontré
John Bolton qui était le conseiller à la
sécurité de Donald Trump et qui était
donc présent aussi bien à Singapour que
Hanoï lui était très contre y compris
les rencontres mais il a eu cette phrase
il dit lorsque vous avez en face de vous
des gens qui sont déterminés à avoir
acquérir l'harmonie claire par par
conviction vous pouvez faire tout ce que
vous voulez vous n'arriverez jamais à
les empêcher et donc il y avait lui
avait cette position assez fataliste qui
était de dire
Trump a cru qu'il pouvait aussi parce
qu'il avait besoin d'un accord il
voulait courir il était d'une certaine
manière en rivalité avec Obama qui avait
fait l'accord avec l'Iran et donc lui il
voulait pouvoir son succès diplomatique
et il voulait dénucléariser
qu'est-ce qu'il en reste il en reste une
tentative de de dialogue qui je pense
avaient ces mérites et effectivement
traiter un pays en paria éternellement
je pense ça n'a conduit à rien ça m'a
permis que de permettre à la Corée du
Nord finalement de de garder son régime
le plus autoritaire qui soit et de
développer son armement donc parce que
le prix qu'on lui fait payer les
sanctions etc n'est pas un prix d'un
prix qu'elle est prête à payer quand on
met 25% de son budget dans le le
département militaire c'est qu'on est
prêt à sacrifier tout le reste de la
société il y a une chose quand même
qu'on peut rappeler sur cette visite
cette rencontre plutôt entre Donald
Trump et Kim Jong-un c'est Kim Jong-un
n'a pas tout perdu non plus il a quand
même réussi il y a quelque chose qui me
semble que mon père n'avait pas réussi
c'est être en bilatérale directement
avec la avec les États-Unis pendant des
années dans les années 2000 il y a eu
pour parler à 5 des rôles de
dénucléaires réalisations et à chaque
fois sa capotait et sa capotait en
partie parce que la Corée du Nord
voulait un dialogue unique avec et
comment dire à une reconnaissance par
les États-Unis
ça devient signifier à la Corée du Nord
et qui me jongle réussi son pari je suis
le président et je peux parler des
galets égales avec un homologue
américain
oui moi je pense que ce qui pourrait
faire changer un petit peu la situation
peut-être
enfin voilà faire évoluer ce serait la
signature d'un traité de paix les
Nord-Coréens ont réclamé à multiples
reprises et puis c'est vrai que négocier
une baisse des sanctions etc dégage de
confiance je pense que ça ça
affaiblirait finalement la légitimité du
régime nord-coréen à avoir cette
stratégie
américaine et européenne est-ce qu'on
doit s'impliquer est-ce qu'on doit se
rapprocher je le disais un peu en
introduction comme ça se rapprocher du
monstre est-ce qu'on va le faire je
pense qu'il faut absolument apprendre à
mieux connaître la Corée du Nord
justement les subtilités de ce régime le
fait de refuser
commencé à en Corée du Sud ils ont pas
accès aussi internet nord-coréen je
trouve ça très dommage en fait plus même
si on a une connaissance de la
propagande ça ça donne des choses à dire
justement sur sur ce régime et je pense
que l'exclusion la punition en fait on a
bien vu que ça ne ça ne portait pas ses
fruits du tout tout ce que nous avons
essayé jusqu'à ce jour les quatre
dernières décennies donc de mettre en
place pour essayer de normaliser
progressivement réinsérer la Corée du
Nord dans un champ politique ou humain
normal à échoué pendant ce temps-là les
arsenaux balistiques et nucléaires eux
donc c'est au fait largement la Corée du
Nord était de plus en plus défiante
écoutant de moins en moins donc la Chine
ce qui est malheureusement donc une
réalité pour Pékin elle a du mal à
vendre un petit peu cette situation mais
il a pas en position autant de force que
ça
elle a un ascendant évident mais lorsque
les nord-corens font la tête à Pékin
Pékin est contraint un petit peu de
d'avaler cette couleur avec un petit peu
de difficulté donc en fait tous la
patience stratégique qu'elle entend
était la marque de fabrique de
l'administration Obama pendant deux
mandats celle qui a suivi à savoir tant
que vous êtes vilain on ne discutera pas
comment ça dénucléariser et nous allions
lancer sanctions et nous vous réinsérons
on signera ce traité de paix on est tout
à fait d'accord les discussions et
n'avaient été plutôt bien engagées
jusqu'à jusqu'en 2018 à ce sujet tout ce
que nous avons tenté n'a produit aucun
résultat si ce n'est le résultat
contraire on est certainement quelque
part dans l'erreur c'est pour conclure
il y a cette allée retour en permanence
en Corée du Sud par rapport à la Corée
du Nord parce que il y avait deux
grandes formations politiques qui qui
ont une alternance là on avait jusqu'à
l'année dernière les partisans de ce
qu'on a appelé la Sunshine policy donc
une politique plus ouverte pour essayer
de faire des petits pas des zones
économiques spéciales de de de les
visites de famille etc qui ça n'a pas
marché là aujourd'hui on est revenu à
une position beaucoup plus dure une
administration sud-coréenne qui joue la
carte des démonstrations de force avec
les Américains là vous avez en ce moment
le plus gros sous-marin nucléaire
américain qui est en train de mouiller
dans les ports
sud-coréens donc on est dans cette
démonstration de force mais à l'arrivée
il faut bien le dire ni l'un ni l'autre
non produit des faits et donc peut-être
qu'il faudrait
un jour inventer une troisième politique
mais pour l'instant l'aller-retour entre
la main tendue ou le bâton
font que rien n'a changé et on
s'arrêtera sur ces questions merci merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à cet échange merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi à très vite sur Public
Sénat à bientôt
merci
[Musique]